foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello good morning and welcome to Sophie
Ridge on Sunday the Prime Minister came
to power promising to be Mr competence
fixing the mistakes of the Liz trust era
but if you promise competence you've got
to be in control and now Richie sunac is
under pressure to show he has got a grip
on our borders on inflation and on
striking workers planning a wave of
walkouts this winter in this week's
Chester by-election with Labor's best
ever result in the city was a reminder
of what is at stake politically so lots
to discuss on today's show with our
guests will be joined on the program by
the conservative chairman Nadeem zahawi
from labor we'll speak to the shadow
education secretary Bridget Phillipson
Germany's ambassador to the UK Miguel
Berger will be here in the studio with
us plus we'll talk China with a former
conservative party leader sir Ian Duncan
Smith
and the culture in the police with a
former assistant commissioner at the Met
Helen King
[Music]
now it was the worst results for the
conservatives in Chester for nearly 200
years if it was replicated at a general
election kistama would be in power with
a comfortable majority no wonder perhaps
that so many conservative MPS have seen
the writings on the wall and have
decided to stand down before the next
election well the man tasked with
pulling The Campaign together is the
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi whose job it is to lead from the
front and we can hear from him now
um thank you so much for being on the
program this morning and if I may I just
want to start away from politics
um because six children under the age of
10 have died after developing the
infection strep hey I know this is
something that so many families can be
really concerned about
how worried should we be about it yes
and I think it's important to highlight
that the UK Health Security Agency uh
have said that in most cases it will be
mild
cases strep a but it is highly
infectious which is why I think the
important message to get across this
morning is parents should look out for
the symptoms so fever headache skin rash
that sort of feeling of the skin being
slightly rough
um really important to be vigilant
because in the very rare circumstance
that it becomes serious then you need
urgent treatment obviously uh yes
certainly um thank you for you know
giving the symptoms I know it's
something that you know definitely lots
of parents in particular will be Keen to
get the full information on
um now you're announcing today what you
describe as sensible contingency
measures in the event of public sector
strikes so what's the plan yes
absolutely well the first plan is to get
these strikes called off I think the
important thing to remember is Putin is
using energy as a weapon uh because he's
failing so badly in this illegal war in
Ukraine uh that energy use by Putin
means we've had very high inflation
rates and we've got to try and bring
down inflation if you chase
um inflation or above inflation in some
cases
um pay then you will embed inflation for
longer and hurt the most vulnerable in
fact which is our message to the unions
is to say you know this is not a time to
strike this is time to try and negotiate
but in the absence of that it's
important for the government it's the
right and responsible thing to do uh to
have contingency plans in place and uh
we have a very strong team at Cobra and
I was when I was in the uh seat of the
chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster uh
we were doing a lot of the work uh in
looking at what we need to do to
minimize the disruption to people's
lives whether you know it's unfair if
you're traveling at Christmas for for
you know the Border force or any other
Workforce to really disrupt people's
lives oh livelihoods and let's look at
the specifics are you talking about the
military being involved soldiers could
be driving ambulances so we're looking
at the military we're looking at a
specialist response Force which we've
actually set up a number of years ago
The Surge capacity to be able to deal
with uh in the unfortunate circumstance
if you do have say a striker border
Force you've got to be able to make sure
that there is minimum disruption the
most important thing is just secure it
could be coming in filling some of these
roles because we have to make sure our
borders are always secure and that is
something that we guarantee and is it
the same in the NHS and again of course
in in things like driving ambulances
um other parts of the public sector
we've got to try and minimize uh
disruption but the way you
um try and deal with this is if the
unions can see that you're chasing
inflation
um uh or above inflation pay deal is not
the thing to do right now this is the
time to come together and to you know
send a very message to Mr Putin that
we're not going to be just just to get
divided in this way just just to look at
the specifics um as well and are you
also looking at using pharmacists to
ease pressure on the NHS as the Sunday
Telegraph is reporting so perhaps
pharmacists being able to diagnose minor
conditions and even prescribe
antibiotics so the hope is obviously
that the NHS and uh if there is a
striking again I hope there isn't a
stroke uh say for example with the
nurses is that there is a minimum safety
level of uh delivery in place uh already
but the NHS will look at all contingency
planning to make sure that that patients
are able to get the urgent treatment
that they need cooking you could be
looking at Pharmacists playing a bigger
role well the NHS will will make sure
that we we have to be able to deliver a
safe level of treatment and support to
patients students at all times and I
hope again I would put it back to the
unions himself to say one we shouldn't
be striking if you look at what uh the
pay review bodies for the NHS
recommended we've accepted that
recommendation uh in fact last year when
pay was Frozen
um nurses got a three percent pay rise
they do an incredible job of course I
understand that but to ask for 19 pay
rise which cost the NHS 10 billion
pounds I think it's it's the wrong thing
to do right because I do want to come
back on this as well because you know
you're talking about not chasing
inflation for lots of people who are on
low-pay jobs they're not chasing
inflation they're trying to get a pay
that is matching the cost of living
because they're looking at their
shopping Bills going on and looking at
their energy Bills going up they want to
pay to be reflecting how much more
they're having to spend on things it's
not about embedding inflation for them
it's about surviving of course and
absolutely which is why the chancellor
came to the dispatch box and delivered a
150 billion pound energy package that's
by the way if you take that into
equivalence that's equivalent of the
whole of the NHS to support people's
households otherwise their energy bills
would have uh spiked to support
businesses as well the money we're
putting into helping those most
vulnerable uh the 8 million most
vulnerable households
um is significant we have to come
together this is not a time to be
divided to I hope send a very clear
message to Mr Putin that he can't use
energy as a weapon in this way and we
will remain United which is why we've
accepted accepted the pay-per-view
bodies I guess NHS I guess and on
schools 20 grand a year you you would
think that maybe there are other ways of
sending Putin a clear message on Ukraine
rather than the fact that you're going
to have to well no have a real term but
we wake up no but we've accepted the the
pay review body on nurses and as I said
to you last year they got three percent
the this year's recommendation is 1400
pounds so the uh you know the starting
salary of a nurse would be a 31 000
pounds it is difficult I am absolutely
you know conscious of the fact of how
hard things are at the moment but it's
not a time to you know go for 19 pay
rise that will cost 10 billion pounds
because if you you know if you accept
all the inflation uh level pay Rises
that's about 28 billion pounds it costs
every household just short of a thousand
pounds
um that is you know unsustainable when
we're trying to be fiscally disciplined
and bring inflation under control
because if inflation is embedded it'll
hurt those families those nurses even
more in the long term now I want to talk
about immigration
um because we've seen record levels of
immigration record numbers of small
boats crossing the channel as well
um many people voted for brexit to be
able to control Britain's borders are we
in control of them so on illegal
migration small boats and these gangs
that are preying on the vulnerabilities
of putting lives at risk
um we have a plan the Prime Minister
within weeks are we in control of our
borders well of course we are in control
of our borders but there is an issue
around these small boats and these gangs
and illegal migration and the Prime
Minister within weeks of taking power
signed an agreement with France to
increase uh the number of patrols by I
think about 40 percent which will help
on this uh they've already turned back
about 30 000 uh people who would have
come across the numbers are still far
too high I I recognize that and again I
spent some time in the cabinet office
looking at this we are determined to
deal with it this prime minister
determined to deal with it they're at no
easy solutions but there are a number of
things that we can do including
operationalizing Rwanda uh to actually
send a very clear message to these you
know gangs that this will not work and I
think the moment that happens you'll see
the number begin to drop rapidly as we
saw when when if you remember under
Theresa may we dealt with the issue of
people coming across uh being smuggled
in in trucks talking about and reduce
that and took it to to near zero so it's
important to focus on it and then on
legal migration uh we need to make sure
that we you know focus on if there is
any abuse of the legal migration system
if there are people you know for example
um our universities do a brilliant job
and it's a great export for the UK
people are coming here doing their phds
and their masters and you know creating
in you know new Innovative things for
the British economy but if there's an
abuse of the system then we should stamp
that out as well so you are looking then
at reduced the number of foreign
students coming to University no I
didn't say that okay um what I said to
you is Forest students coming to our
universities are a great export these
are you're really really uh important to
uh us and of course our economy okay um
to our really high quality universities
but if there is abuse and there was in
the past I remember some time back you
know bogus University setting up
understanding the Kebab shops on them
illegal migration because there was
another question I was Keen to squeeze
in on this and there's a report by Nick
Timothy who of course was the chief of
staff to Theresa May who recommends
Banning people who enter the UK through
illegal routes from ever settling in the
United Kingdom they should not be a need
for people to come through on an illegal
uh route because
if you have a legitimate right
um to settlement to Refuge then you
should be able to settle here and it's
right that we should address the issue
of illegal migrants so you are
potentially considering Banning people
who enter the UK legally from ever well
look that's initial that's the question
for the Home Secretary what I'm saying
to you is we've got to deal with the
gangs that are exploiting people putting
lives at risk on these small boats and I
am absolutely certain that the Prime
Minister and the Home Secretary are
focused on this no easy answers but we
will absolutely deliver against this in
the weeks and months to come now I want
to talk to you with your party chair at
hat on if I may you know you're
responsible for campaigning you've got a
big role in election planning as well so
I just want to look at the states of the
conservative party right now you know
this is the current tracker poll from
you go if you can see there has been you
know slight narrowing I guess at the
polls but it's been nothing like you
know a big bounce for Rishi sunac
um Labor's still well ahead and of
course if these polls were replicated in
an election it'll be kissed armor in
Downing stream How concerned are you so
when you ask people and I know a little
bit about polling yeah because I founded
Hugo well here you go it's a bit awkward
looking for your company
pulses including Hugo but if you
actually look beneath the headline a
couple of things I would pull out uh
from that uh one when you ask people the
question if there is an election
tomorrow how would you vote well people
know there's no election tomorrow so
that response what you're seeing there
is currently there how they feel about
the the the government's track record on
delivery now we know we've had a
difficult time you know we've had a
difficult time I've been on uh this show
and other shows having to explain why
we're you know uh going through this
sort of difficult period in the
Parliamentary party uh and in our
leadership
um we're in rebuilding mode now to make
sure that we you know be
ready and fit for purpose for the local
elections next year and then for a
general election in 2024. now if you dig
beneath the data I'd be worried if I was
kissed armor because you'd be worried if
you're okay
I'm going to tell you for one if you'll
allow me right if you if you look at his
numbers it's very soft there's not a
great passion for what Kirsten certainly
there's no passion for him when he went
before the Trade union Congress saying
he'll repeal all of the Trade union
legislation that the conservatives have
brought in he's made that promise and if
you ask that same people is that a good
thing or a bad thing I think most of
them will say it's a bad thing but we
are in a rebuilding exercise we've got
to rebuild that trust with the public so
that began with a Chance of exchequer
and the Autumn statement to deal with
inflation when we bring inflation back
under control in the Bank of England
that's independent we'll do that they
have all the tools available to them but
we have a responsibility to help them
because we have fiscal responsibility to
do that when we've done that when we've
delivered on Innovation that 20 billion
investment we've delivered on skills
when we've delivered on the
infrastructure that people want to see
in their constituencies and small boats
it's a real problem for us right then
you'll see those numbers move in the
right direction I'm confident of that
and if you can't deliver on things like
small boats we will that's my point
about rebuilding is it true that cchq is
now ranking conservative MPS on how many
leaflets they deliver and how many doors
they knock on apart according to the
times they use Theresa May as an example
pointing out that she's out twice a week
is that right I like all candidates all
MPS as they do themselves by the way to
be out on the doorstep knocking on doors
engaging with their constituents it's
the right thing to do who's the best
performer well there's lots of great
performers and you will see by the way
the phones are ringing at cchq people
have come back people are supporting us
the atmosphere in the building I think
is incredibly positive and as I said to
you we'll continue to build we've got
local elections great councilors great
candidates for local elections uh next
May and then of course for the uh
election whenever the Prime Minister
comes it's interesting because you're
talking there about the positive
atmosphere in cchq and I have to say and
if you take a step back and look at the
country right now the conservatives of
course been in power for 12 years we've
got record any waiting times we're
spending more on debt interest payments
than education whether it's the time
you're waiting to book a driving test or
the backlogs in the court you know it
feels like this is a country that is
breaking at the seams you know why would
anyone vote for the conservatives who've
been in power presiding over this well
because
I was close to this we delivered the
most successful vaccination program
in this constant history probably in the
world where we've protected the nation
and you see what's happening in
countries today look at what's happening
in China vis-a-vis dealing with the
pandemic today we've dealt with that
pandemic during that period Richie sunac
as Chancellor this exchecker to put over
400 billion pounds to work to protect
people's livelihoods and of course jobs
we've done it again just now because
Putin is using energy as a weapon 150
billion pound energy package three
million businesses protected that would
have gone to the wall perfectly viable
because we know as well that the
household that would have struggled the
150 billion pounds of additional help
for people if you take all of that that
has to be paid for right then of course
we have the recovery the NHS has to
recover from the pandemic that is
happening now we've dealt with a
two-year waiting list by next April
we'll deal with the 18 month waiting
list and of course we've got a a package
for Christmas at the moment to make sure
the NHS gets through Christmas a 500
million package to get people into
social care a big investment in Social
care all these things are happening but
the onus is on us to demonstrate to the
public to show by doing particularly
that is what we're doing particularly
because we just had a conservative prime
minister who crashed the economy became
the shortest serving PM ever and had a
u-turn on her entire budget well I'm
going to repeat what Jeremy Hunt said
the chancellor he said you know that
mini budget was reversed within three
weeks even the obr would say to you that
that's not the impact on the economy the
obr in fact said the office for Budget
responsibility the impact on the economy
is because of Putin's and they have also
said they all they have also talked
about the impact of the mini budget but
they said they're not purely but they
said the international factors
you're quite right but they said the the
predominant okay bulk of the impact okay
was because of Putin using energy as a
weapon we mustn't forget that has a
price and we have to continue to support
Ukraine and Vladimir zielinski because
this illegal War has to end with Russia
leaving Ukraine there are reports uh
that some conservative MPS believe that
Boris Johnson may still be the answer to
your election issues shall we say here's
Stephen swinford in the times Boris
Johnson supporters are convinced that
sunac will fall and that Johnson will
replace him with the May local elections
seen as a focal point you know you're
obviously back to sports Johnson to be a
leader do you still speak to him I speak
to Boris Johnson I in fact I spoke for
him in his constituency of either a
conversation with the chairman of the
party let me tell you what Boris Johnson
thinks as he did when he reflected and
stepped aside and supported Rishi sunak
he said I will not be selfish I will put
country and party ahead and Rishi has
the overwhelming support of the
Parliamentary party which is why he
supported him that was the right thing
to do we have to remain United we've got
local elections coming up next year and
we've got a whole delivery program on
health of course on education and of
course safer streets and small boats
that we've got to deliver against that
is what Boris Johnson is focused on at
the moment okay no chance then he'll
that he'll come back as leader no
because having another leadership
election will be a Surefire way of us
losing uh in elections okay and one
question that I just want to ask before
we finish
um which is about the allegations around
a conceptive at MP
um the victims we understand or alleged
victims haven't made formal complaints
but a number of conservative MPS have
made
um complaints or reports about this
person's alleged Behavior
should they be suspended from the
concepted party well this is a very
important safeguarding question and I
the moment I walked into the building at
conserve headquarters I asked an
independent for independent legal advice
on this issue as well as our own
in-house legal
advice on the case we also spoke to the
house authorities we spoke to the
priority ethics team on this and it is
up to the police because these
allegations are third party allegations
that have been handed to the police
we've spoken to the I spoke to the
police as well of course and if the
police decide to take action then of
course we will take action as well okay
uh just finally
England playing later today indeed are
you gonna be watching of course is it
coming home
it will I'm not going to sing that song
or go anywhere near it because every
time I've done that it has broken my
heart okay thank you very much indeed
for being on the program
at Nadeem it's a highway there the Chad
the conceptive party well let's go and
get Labor's take this morning uh shall
we because we can talk to the shadow
education secretary Richard Phillipson
who joins us now thanks so much for
being with us we just heard from Nadeem
zahari I showed him some uh polling
which shows how far ahead the labor
party is but he says it's kirstama who
should be worried right now do you think
that's right
foreign
no I don't think that's right I mean
we're not complacent about things and
the only pool that matters is the pool
that we see on general election day but
we've made massive progress as a party
and we're the only people setting out a
Clear Vision for how Britain could be
better and Labor's plan would mean we
deliver well-paid highly skilled jobs in
every corner of our country and we get
our economy growing once more something
we haven't seen over these last 12 years
and as you say you know you are doing
well in the polls and so I'm quite Keen
to try and find out a bit more of what
you say is a Clear Vision of what you
know a labored government would look
like what the country under labor would
look like you say you'll deliver more
jobs fairness I mean these are things
that no one would disagree with but I'm
just gonna I'm Keen to get a bit more of
a sense about you know the sort of
values and the principles that occur
with government would entail so would
you spend more money on public services
and than conservatives
well we don't yet know what the
situation will be with the public
finances the conservatives crash the
economy and an incoming labor government
is likely to inherit a very difficult
situation and that will mean we have to
make difficult choices around public
money but we also have choices of calls
as well about how we raise money that's
why I believe that we should end the tax
benefits that private schools enjoy and
invest in a brilliant State education
for every child driving up high
standards right across our schools but
you know we're not in a position right
now of course given the very uncertain
nature of the economy to set out exact
figures and what that first Labor budget
would look like
okay and I will talk to you about the
education staff and give you the space
to talk about your policy um later in
the interview
um not completely clear from that
question whether you'd spend more on
public services than the conservatives
and how about immigration and we've got
record levels of immigration and nadims
are high was saying that it's too high
the conservatives want to bring down
particularly illegal migration what's
Labor's position would you like to see
immigration higher or lower
I think my starting point is that
immigration has always been an important
part of our national story as a country
I wouldn't be stood here speaking to you
today where enough for the fact that my
grandparents came to this country from
Ireland worked in the NHS and helped to
build our country but I do recognize at
the same time that we need to make sure
we're investing in the skills of people
here that we're giving everyone the
opportunity to succeed so there is a
balance to strike and that's why we
would maintain a point space system
where it comes to immigration
okay and that's clear on the
points-based system certainly um but can
we talk about strikes now because again
it's another issue that I think so many
people will have you know big questions
about and public sector workers want a
pay rise to match inflation so inflation
obviously currently around 11 Nadeem
zahari says that would be unsustainable
it'll be unaffordable what is Labor's
position would you give inflation
matching pay Rises to public sector
workers
I completely recognize that right across
our Public Services whether that's
nurses or teachers they've been terribly
let down by this government and they
want a fair deal and that is around pay
but it's also about terms and conditions
the fact that so many people working in
our public services are burnt out feel
that they have a government that is
completely abandoned them onto the last
Labor government we made sure that we
invested in our Workforce that we made
sure they were paid properly for the
amazing job that they are doing and I
think that is incredibly important but
as I say pay is one very important
element of this but if you speak to head
teachers or School support staff as I do
right across the country they just feel
you know overworked let down and really
badly demoralized and that's why it'll
be the job of an incoming labor
government to demonstrate that we want
to work with the people the amazing
people in our public services to make
sure that you don't have to wait months
on end to get access to a hospital
appointment the fact that children in
all of our schools have opportunities to
succeed and that we don't end up in this
position as we are now where staff are
having to put their hands in their own
pocket in order to make sure that
children don't go hungry when they
arrive at school and Labor's plan around
breakfast clubs making sure that every
child in our country gets a brilliant
start to the day is part of how we make
life a lot better and easier for staff
working in our Public Services too and I
just want to come back because the
question was specifically about pay
um you say that you would like to see a
fair deal a public sector workers should
be paid properly but but you know the
difficult thing is working out what that
means would you like to see inflation
matching pay rises in the public sector
I want to see a fair deal for all of our
workers right across Public Services of
course this is all about negotiation and
compromise
they want to see a fair deal the
question is what is that don't negotiate
well I do think it means recognizing the
pressure that people are under right now
but also over the last 12 years uh pay
hasn't been keeping up with demands that
workers in our Vital services are facing
but you can't get to a position of
agreement if you're not prepared to even
have that conversation and what I hear
time and again you know whether it's
real or our schools or the Health
Service ministers are just not prepared
to sit down and talk about these issues
properly we won't get an agreement and
we won't get a negotiated settlement but
all sides can live with if ministers
just say well there's nothing to do with
me you know if I was Secretary of State
for Education I'd be around the table
try to get a solution working with trade
unions to find a find a way through all
of this not stalking tension as
ministers all too often seem intent on
doing
um I don't know what um you know we
started the interview talking about the
polls it's pretty clear how well they
were doing with the polls if they were
replicated in a general election like
that result in Chester then you would
have a majority so I get you know that
there is obviously a desire in Labor uh
right now to not scare the horses
effectively to kind of play it safe and
then you'll hopefully get as you say say
uh you know that majority at the next
election but
I guess there's a bit of a frustration
sometimes interviewing people from labor
when it does feel like you're being a
bit reluctant to nail your colors to the
Mast on public sector pay for example
it's almost like you don't want to put
off either side in the debate by saying
that you want a fair deal you want
everyone to talk but I'm not really
clear on whether or not you think that
inflation matching pay Rises are
unaffordable or if you're saying that
it's something that actually the
government should do whatever happens
foreign
because I think trust in politics
matters and I'm not going to make
promises this morning to you that I
don't feel confident I can deliver I
think that's been what so what's been so
corrosive to our politics in recent
years is Tory politicians in particular
saying one thing and doing another so
yes absolutely I want to see a better
deal for the brilliant people that work
right across our education system and a
part of that is around the choices that
we make around how we find investment
and our policy on private schools around
ending those tax breaks and putting that
1.7 billion pounds into more teachers in
our classrooms into better mental health
support for all of our children and are
making sure that all of our staff are
properly supported that's one I think
really straightforward way the
government right now could be doing
things differently and that's a clear
divide that you see between labor and
the conservatives our focus on high
standards and all of our brilliant State
schools but on driving up standards
further and Richie sunak who isn't
prepared to stand up to the vested
interests in his own party and isn't
prepared to do what's right by children
and families in our country
um you're also calling for a regulatory
investigation into private schools just
to explain what that's about
seen uh for years now are fees going up
often very substantially and you know I
think there needs to be a full
investigation into whether that market
is operating effectively we've heard
Lots about landish claims from Jeremy
Hunt and from Richie soonack and others
about the impact of Labor's policy which
I just don't think are born out by the
evidence but if you look at the fees
that private schools are charging right
now they have gone up Way Beyond
earnings in cash terms and I think it is
important that the CME investigate this
matter and see whether this Market is
working properly I think it does now
fall to the Secretary of State for
education to whom I've written to make
sure that matter is referred to the CME
and that they look into it but who's
whose side is she on is she on the side
of parents on the side of children on
delivering a brilliant education for all
of our children or is she not prepared
diet that stand up to the vested
interests in our own party
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh this morning Bridget
Phillips in there for the labor party
well you're watching at Stacey Ridge on
Sunday we've heard from the
conservatives uh and we've also heard
from the labor party in India Sahari
telling us that the government was
looking to bring in the military if
strikes go ahead in the Health Service
Plus still to come on the program this
morning in just a moment we'll talk to
the former conservative leader City and
Duncan Smith about what to do about
China a little later we'll hear from a
former assistant commissioner of the net
police Helen King about whether the UK's
public institutions are doing enough to
Stamp Out racism and misogyny plus we'll
be getting some immediate reaction from
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
they've been watching all of our
interviews as well so we'll talk to Sam
a bit later on as well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now the UK may be on its third prime
minister this year but one thing hasn't
changed the deadlock over post brexit
trade agreements with uh Northern
Ireland however this week the European
Union said it was encouraged by its
first talks with Rishi sunak joining us
now is the German ambassador to the UK
Miguel Berger thank you so much for
being with us this morning
um it's been a bumpy few months for the
UK uh shall we say you know partly
because of global factors like inflation
uh partly because of domestic issues as
well and what do you think the UK is
currently perceived from abroad
yeah I would say that everybody is glad
to see that financial markets are now
again more stable but the challenges you
have described we are all facing them
high inflation Energy prices going up
governments struggling to get the
necessary support for business and
private households so I would say there
is also quite some understanding for the
challenges yeah those challenges as you
say um experienced by countries across
Europe the rest of the world as well and
what do you see as the you know Way
Forward for that
I think we have to be aware that this
energy crisis will not go away after
winter because we will have zero Russian
gas in Europe and Russia has been by far
the largest supplier that means that not
only Germany the whole of Europe UK will
have to get cash from the international
markets and that means for the next one
and a half two years we might face a
situation with high energy prices let's
talk a bit about Ukraine
um shall we because I think the German
Chancellor spoke to Vladimir Putin this
week on the phone he urged him to
withdraw troops and to try and find a
diplomatic solution and is Germany
optimistic about a way out of the wall
we are not yet optimistic we don't see a
fundamental change in the Russian
position
Putin continues this really terrorizing
the civilian population and we are very
concerned about that because these
attacks on the energy infrastructure
mean that many people with freezing
temperatures might be forced to leave
Ukraine so we expect another wave of
refugees in the coming weeks so but to
your question no we don't see for the
foreseeable future a willingness to
engage in the Diplomatic solution in the
conversation Allah Schultz also vowed to
continue German support for Ukraine and
there has been some criticism hasn't
there that Germany was a bit slow for
Mark in offering support to Ukraine
perhaps you can have done a little bit
more as some would say in terms of
Military Support as well I think we can
show that you know the different amounts
that countries have spent on weapons and
equipment to Ukraine it's the numbers
just on the left there you can see the
us at the top followed by the EU but
both Poland and the UK above Germany
despite having smaller populations
should Germany do more
I think these figures are not correct
because we have sent many weapon systems
which were written off
so for example the anti-aerial Gay Part
tanks which were already been written
off so we can't have them in this
statistic as new tanks so I would not
give too much on it but my feeling is
that we start at the middle a little bit
later than others but in the end if you
look at the amount of weapon systems
especially I receive anti-aerial
missiles they are extremely effective
100 of Russian missiles attacking TF at
the last rate were shot down so I would
say we are doing all quite well and I
guess there's been action on energy as
well in the ee2 where there is obviously
more of a dependence on Russian oil and
gas yeah but this has been dramatically
reduced but let me say on weapons I
think the key issue is that we continue
to send weapons and ammunition and
assure maintenance of the equipment we
have sent over the coming months only if
that happens Russia will understand that
they will not really be able to to
defeat your Ukraine so this is I think
the key challenge for all of us
um before we move on to brexit which I
do want to do um I just want to ask you
a question on China because we've seen
some really extraordinary protests in
China recently
um originally about the lockdown but
also spilling over to
um other issues as well um Chancellor
Schultz announced recently that Germany
is going to try and reduce its
dependence on trade with China that
would be quite difficult to do though
wouldn't it it's a challenge for all of
us and I think the key issue is that we
have to diversify our trade relations so
we have to look at our weaknesses the
weaknesses like for example
semiconductors batteries Rare Earth so
we have to invest in Western production
try to reassure certain industries but
let me say that we are working in
Germany on a new China strategy and we
are cooperating whether very closely
with the British government which are
which is doing the update of the
integrated review so I would say we are
analyzing together the challenges of
China it's interesting that the UK and
Germany you see is perhaps working
together to get a new sort of strategy
on this then yes and we have to do that
I think if there is one lesson of
Russia's war of aggression is that we
have to reduce dependencies from China
um now there's been lots of speculation
in the UK but Rishi sunx approach to
brexit
um are you optimistic that there could
be some kind of breakthrough uh in the
disagreement about the Northern Ireland
protocol I think that we have now a
different basis for negotiations I see
an openness to engage they have already
been talks and yes I would say I'm
cautiously optimistic because in the end
there is a landing zone for the Northern
Ireland protocols implementation it is
possible to find a solution the
difficult issue is is more the political
on the reaction of the dup the risk of a
of an election in Northern Ireland so
there are many political issues which go
together with it but if we speak about
the negotiation process I would say I'm
cautiously optimistic that's interesting
do you think then that Russia Cena has a
different attitude a different set of
priorities perhaps to list trust and
perhaps also Boris Johnson
yeah I I would say that even less trust
made some steps towards Europe she
participated in Prague at the first
meeting of the European political
community and the first talks were
already under this trust with James
cleverly so um I would say we see in
general a different attitude maybe it
has also to do with the war in Ukraine
that everybody understands that in the
west we have more important challenges
to face and that democracy should work
together and should be able to sort out
an issue like Northern Ireland with the
um you know you talk about the the
threat from Ukraine and Russia but also
obviously we are facing an economic
crisis as well right with energy bills
and given that do you think that there
is a desire both from the EU side but
also from the British side I guess to
have a closer relationship I would say
yes and it has always been the position
of the German government that we want a
relationship as close as possible with
the United Kingdom and yes you mentioned
energy this is a perfect example if we
look at the challenges electricity
supply for the UK in Winter a lot of LNG
went through the UK to Germany to the
center of Europe so energy is a perfect
example of of an area where we should
cooperate to Mutual Advantage there's
been speculation about so-called Swiss
steel which effectively means you know
access to the single Market it would
come with greater contributions to the
EU budget and also more immigration from
Europe as well officially the UK
government has ruled out but I guess
what I'm interested in is would that
even be a possibility would it even be
something that would be on the table
from the European side
I would say that we welcome that there
is a discussion about this kind of we
don't have to go into the details of the
Swiss model but that the government or
parts of the government are thinking
about how to have a better and closer
relationship with the European Union is
something that that we see very
positively
it feels that kirstan is perhaps
reluctant to talk too much about brexit
he of course was a very strong remainer
um would you like to see a stronger line
from labor
I think that's really the decision that
labor has to take but we see also very
positively that labor is willing to have
a very close relationship with Europe
and I think the rest we will have to
leave it now to the negotiations because
if we achieve a solution on Northern
Ireland then this will help also to
develop other areas of cooperation so I
would see the solution of the Northern
Ireland protocol question as a first
step and there will be others then to
follow
um the let's talk about an independent
Scotland here in the UK as well if
Scotland was to vote for Independence
um would they have to adopt the euro to
join the EU
you know I don't really want to get into
okay
but let me put it like that every
country that is joining uh the European
Union and we are currently negotiating
with some countries in the western
Balkans know that they have to introduce
the Euro
um interesting um and then just finally
could you see a position in the future
where the UK joins the single Market
very difficult to predict I would say
let's take it step by step
um but in Germany obviously there is a a
lot of interest in having as I said the
United Kingdom as close as possible so
Europe and to Germany uh thank you um
now I'm sorry to bring in staff but the
World Cup is of course still going on uh
Germany are out thanks to a winning goal
from Japan against Spain that knocked
you out and there was a pretty
controversial VAR decision uh in the
lead up to that goal that this it was
ruled that this ball didn't go out of
play
do you agree just look at this picture
that the ball didn't cross the line
yeah it seems that the ball was in maybe
three four millimeters but you know in
the end this doesn't matter because
Germany should never have lost the match
the first match against Japan so let me
only say really good luck for the
english team tonight against Senegal um
oh they're going to be supporting
England against Senegal then yeah it
will be an interesting match to watch
um and just finally I just want to show
you this picture of the German team
because they were certainly a team who
tried to make their voices heard in
Qatar covering their mouths there to
send a very clear message that they
weren't allowed to I should guess show
their
um disagreements with some of the
qataris positions on human rights
um were you proud of the German team for
doing this and would you have liked to
see more coordinate in action from
European teams on this yeah let me say I
was really proud of seeing seeing them
because it was a very controversial
discussion about the World Cup in Qatar
as it was in the United Kingdom and
especially this very appalling interview
by the head of FIFA Mr Infantino so I
think if there is one conclusion out of
that is that we should only have this
big sporting events in countries which
respect workers rights and respect basic
human rights that's interesting to hear
you say that so uh firmly I think many
people would agree with that analysis as
well thank you so much for being on the
program this morning good to have you
here thank you thank you
and now as usual the take will follow at
this program that's just after 9 30.
it's our chance to analyze today's
interviews talk through any news lines
with our Deputy political editor uh Sam
coats but we can get a quick take from
Sam just now on things that stood out to
him uh this morning uh good to hear from
you Sam it's been quite a wide-ranging
show whether it's you know strikes and
small boats with Nadim zahawi whether
it's what a future labor government
would look like I was also very
interested to hear from the German
ambassador about his optimism for the
brexit talks as well what what stood out
to you
good morning Sophie yes so much to talk
about after 9 30 but I want to start
just with one thing right now that's the
issue that's going to cause so many
headaches for people in the run-up to
Christmas and that is strikes with a
different form of industrial
action-facing different people every day
until Christmas what was fascinating
about the way that Nadine zahawi engaged
on the subject of strikes was that he
didn't go full blown he didn't do
full-blown criticism of the unions in
this big debate which is going to affect
so many people's lives he did what toys
don't often do and adopted a relatively
moderate tone towards the fact that so
many people are going out on strike for
instance he was making Vladimir Putin
not union bosses the big enemy in this
dispute you and I Sophie have covered so
many different bits of industrial action
where it's quite clear that Tories don't
like holding back when it comes to the
union they love to do not love nothing
more than to bash them and I think that
that reflects a bigger squeamishness a
bigger uncertainty at the hunks of
government over how to deal with this
industrial action could they tighten
strike laws well they haven't decided
yet will they bash the union leaders in
the weeks to come or do they think that
not doing so might help them get a deal
Over The Line in certain sectors I think
that Rishi Suna is not naturally the
kind of bombast who likes to go out and
publicly punch his enemies but that
makes him quite an unusual political
leader in doing so okay thank you very
much indeed Sam and we'll have more from
Sam at 9 30 in safe Ridge on Sunday the
take now the recent protests in China
have stunned the world they began in
response to the country's stripped
covert restrictions but eventually
developed in some places to a call for
an end to communist Rule and the harsh
Crackdown on protesters has highlighted
the difficulties that many Western
countries have in dealing with China
well joining us now is the formal
conservative party leader Ian Duncan
Smith thank you so much for being on the
program
um I'm very keen to talk to you about
China but just first we've just heard
from the German ambassador I was quite
interested in what he said on brexit he
said that he was quite optimistic that
there would be a change in tone on the
talks on Northern Ireland that there
would be a closer relationship between
the EU and the UK and what's your sort
of sense of where Rishi Cena is when it
comes to president well I think the
truth is it's not really where is sunak
is I think because I think he would love
to have a good engagement I think
there's a big question mark for what the
European Union wants to do because in
the protocol it's quite clear that two
things one Good Friday agreement trumps
everything else and at the moment we
have a problem because consent doesn't
take place in Northern Ireland so which
is why the unions have walked away from
the assembly and the second thing is
very important article 13.8 make it
absolutely clear is there any problems
with the protocol the protocol can be
changed in whole or in part right now Mr
cescovich does not have the power to
negotiate on 13.8 which is critical
because it's not working so what we're
doing at the moment is still a slight
kind of elaborate dance around this at
the heart of this is article 13.8 I know
it sounds technical but it says the
protocol can be changed in whole or in
part it's not working we should be
discussing that and both sides reach an
agreement which allows them to respect
each other's Market requirements I think
that's the key okay interesting perhaps
slightly further away uh maybe not yeah
um okay and now you are one of the most
outspoken critics of China you've
previously been sanctioned by them for
speaking out about the uyghurs so I'm
interested to know your thoughts on the
you know the extraordinary scenes we've
seen recently are people taken to the
streets to protest uh initially of
course about the anti-lockdown rules of
those sort of lockdown rules um do you
think change could be happening in China
I I we the trouble is I think with all
of us in the west is that we're uh
basically all decent people who believe
in democracy Freedom human rights all
the rest of it whether you're in Germany
or in France or in Britain or wherever
on America our tendency is we always
want to believe that the good is coming
and that somehow the natural order of
things is democracy human rights and the
rule of law but with China I think we
have to have a reality check this is a
brutal dictatorial government that
thinks nothing of incarcerating people
it's carrying out genocide amongst the
uyghur in xinjiang I mean literally
slave labor products we buy have got
slave labor in them here all around the
Western World we've done very little to
stop that so this is a a government that
thinks nothing of cracking down so their
control is total they use technology in
a way that we just couldn't imagine over
here all of that tells me that they're
not going anywhere soon they are
determined that their former government
is right and they will not let up so
once they won't modify around the edges
because the covert issues causing them
economic problems as well I don't think
we should overread this at all president
XI is absolutely determined that the
form of government China has is the
former government for everywhere and
he's selling it to the uh the developing
world right now are you a very strong in
your condemnation of what you see it's a
brutal regime what ship of the UK
government response how should we go
about our relationship well I'm deeply
disappointed in my government over this
particular area because of course you
know president the Prime Minister said
during the summer that he thought that
China represented a systemic threat and
then recently he's shifted that to
systemic challenge the problem with
challenges it looks weak and we've now
got a policy which it sounds like it
could have come from Sir Humphrey in Yes
Minister which is robust pragmatism now
if somebody can please tell me what
robust pragmatism means it means nothing
robust but also pragmatic they cancel
each other out the reality we've got to
do is we've got to change our integrated
review to put China in as a systemic
threat the Americans are way ahead of us
on this other countries in Europe are
talking about it we the UK could risk
being left behind dragging our feet it
from that everything flows from that
about how we relate to China what does
that mean in Practical terms I mean I
know you've talked a bit about smart
meters for example before are there any
kind of concrete examples of what
acknowledging or saying that China was a
systematic threat would mean being a
systemic threat then going into the
integrated route as a threat as Russia
was means that everything that the
government does then flows from that
point so it means that you can no longer
be ambivalent about what China does you
have to view it in the light of it being
a threat so that means for example we've
got illegal I think they're illegal but
the government seems to turn a blind eye
to them Chinese police stations bullying
Chinese expats to go back they're not
alone in this they're in all sorts of
countries Holland the Netherlands
Germany all these countries but they're
being much more aggressive about it the
Holland has shut down uh theirs the
other day America's kicking them out yet
we seem to be completely ambivalent
about whether or not they're doing this
bullying having video links back to
Beijing with their families brought in
being threatened in front of them if
they don't go back we've got this new
Embassy complex that they want to build
with you the biggest Embassy complex in
the whole of Europe right in the heart
of Europe right next door to the city of
London you know really astonishingly
inept if the government now allows the
appeal to go through we can go on all
these things Confucius Institute spying
on Chinese students our University is
completely dependent on Chinese money
and us as an economy farty dependent on
China a dictator regime none of this can
happen unless we see them as a threat
that's the key the pragmatism is the
economic reality of it right that's how
some would see it at a time when you
know we'll look spiral cancer we are in
a recession do we not need to have that
trade relationship with China for the
good of the economy well it depends what
your trade-off is I think this is a
trade-off in human lives
for me the uyghur being
incarcerated the women sterilized
forcibly sterilized often raped we've
got children in re-education camps we've
got uh just a ton of men in forced labor
camps thousands of miles away from their
family never seeing their family again
that's just one bit of it you've got
Tibet forced labor camps you've got the
Christian churches the Evangelical
Church has been cracked down on arrests
taking place Hong Kong you know people
being arrested for their uh peaceful
democracy campaigns I mean where do you
draw the line do we turn a blind eye to
all of that and say we just go on making
money out of China my answer is
diversify bring some of these
Technologies back to to Europe to the
continent of Europe to Britain to
America actually start looking at India
and others to invest more in to develop
them as a counterbalance can't go on
turning a blind eye to the fact that our
cheaper products come from countries
that use slave labor not on um I just
want to talk to you a little bit as if
at the end about the state of the
conservative party and polling's still
looking pretty difficult to say the
least are you obviously lost at the
Chester by-election that itself wasn't a
surprise but labor achieved their
greatest result there for 200 years
um Nadim zahawi said that looking at the
pulse he thinks kirst armor should be
worried do you think that's right well
interestingly uh John Curtis the day
after said that whilst this would give
labor this result probably a majority he
didn't say a massive majority he was his
point was making that you'd have
expected them to do better I'm not now
going to be clever about this but the
truth is if you're an opposition you
should be winning a by-election like
that midterm with all our problems right
now by a massive degree and it wasn't as
big now having said that we lost it so
the conservatives shouldn't go around
telling themselves all is okay because
it's going to come right in the end it's
like
you're there's about 1200 I think yeah
you could be in trouble yeah well I've
been told I'm in trouble for the last
three elections but I've managed to get
back
um all I would say is concerns shouldn't
be complacent we have to get this
economy growing at the heart of this
life people fears about two things I
think one is obviously about migration
the boat's crossing the channel which is
headline stuff and really worrying
people the second bit importantly though
is growth all the economies of Europe
facing very much the same struggle but
the UK has got now the highest tax rate
that it's had for a generation and we've
got to get that down so we need growth
back in the economy easily by next
spring so that we can start to put these
things right and people can feel better
off with access to jobs and to good
incomes these are the key things that
will winners through at the end not
tokenistic excuses about the fact it
could have been better for labor than it
was um you of course know what it's like
to lead the conservative party in the
depths of opposition do you think you
might be heading back into that
Wilderness all political parties in
government face the prospect of losing
the next election because elections are
about your record often more than they
are about the alternative so the key
question for us is to get the choice
much more difficult for the public
otherwise we would end up going into
opposition and that means making them
make a choice and if we have growth if
we have an economy going forward if you
have people getting jobs livelihoods
looking better people were able to pay
their mortgages and we get that
migration issue under control then we're
in the races and we have a chance of
winning back into government okay it
sounds like a tough Challenge and thank
you very much for being on the program
and speaking I say strongly about China
as well thank you
uh in Duncan Smith there now since the
murder of Sarah Evra the Metropolitan
Police Service has been through a period
of reflection about some officers
attitudes towards women and now the
London fire brigade has also come under
a similar Spotlight after a very
critical review found it to be
institutionally misogynistic and racist
with a toxic culture that allows
bullying and abuse so have lessons not
been learned by Major institutions and
if so why not joining us now is Helen
King a former assistant commissioner at
the Metropolitan Police Service thank
you so much for coming to the studio
this morning it's appreciated good
morning
um I just want to talk about a story
that broke yesterday the head of the
police Watchdog resigning because sir
the police are investigating a
historical allegation about him I mean
you really couldn't make it up
well obviously I don't know any more
than is in the Press already and clearly
what needs to happen is that
investigation needs to go ahead no doubt
the individual concerned is under under
huge pressure and his family and so on
as well and that process has to run but
at the same time everyone the public
complainants police officers need to be
able to have confidence in the iopc as
well and the the the investigations that
they carry out I don't think you're
completely right of course that we don't
know the details of the allegation it
would be absolutely wrong to make any uh
judgments there
um but I guess the police investigation
it seems has been going on for some time
and yet Michael look would only stepped
aside when the Home Secretary told him
to either quit or be suspended it feels
like there's question marks that the
iopc was even aware of the allocation I
as I say I know no more than is in the
Press it's important that the police
complaint system is one that both
officers and the public can have
confidence in and I think one of the the
constructive debate that is happening at
the moment is looking at the way
allegations against the police including
internal police misconduct
investigations are dealt with to make
sure that police Chiefs can sack police
officers where that's appropriate and
that those investigations can be
concluded more quickly and in ways that
have public and officer confidence yeah
to talk about the public confidence in
the police but also other institutions
as well because it does feel like
there's been I guess already almost
classed as like a misfortunately crisis
and some of these institutions and the
London Farm Brigade are described as
institutionally misogynistic and racist
reports of people having a helmets
filled with urine Muslim officers having
pork sausages put in their pockets and
of course the Met police too the some of
the WhatsApp messages exchange between
officers joking about rape and domestic
violence
do you think there is institutional
misogyny and racism in some of these
organizations
um let's be frank the the behaviors
you've described are absolutely
despicable
um and something that both we the public
but also the good the many thousands of
of really good committed officers
firefighters and so on will also find
disgusting and want dealt with
but let's be frank this isn't new I
think in a sense it's good that these
conversations are being had it's
following on from the me too movement
um let's look at Parliament you know
you've been a political correspondent I
suspect that you know there's been
um maybe old boys clubs and and networks
in a wide range of Institutions I think
certainly Parliament is not somewhere to
throw stones I think you're probably
definitely right exactly public and
private sector but absolutely right that
it's now being exposed and of course
those who are put in positions of trust
which police officers firefighters
emergency workers are they do an
incredible job but we need to be able to
have confidence in them so it's right
that these behaviors are exposed and
dealt with but at the same time we need
to think about how do we attract and
keep really good stuff those who have
the moral Courage the ethical resilience
to do these really difficult jobs where
they're dealing with tragedy they're
dealing with horrible situations they're
dealing often with hostility from the
public they feel they're under attack by
the media by politicians and now we look
at the the state of our public services
and the amount of work they're having to
do not always with the resources that
they need
so I think there's a question for all of
us yes for leaders of these institutions
but also for us to say how do we make
sure that we have the public services
that we deserve and we support those who
are doing these incredibly difficult
jobs on our behalf I'm interested on
your thoughts on what what can change
what can actually practically be done
um the report in November exam for
example found some recent examples of
people who are cleared to join the
police when they had past convictions
for indecent exposure assaults on women
even an arrest for rape do you think the
vetting is up to scratch
um voting can always be improved but I
do think it's a blunt tool you can
generally only rely upon convictions
and of course people with the wrong
attitude who are joining for the wrong
reasons
um may be hiding that so you've got to
have the right training you've got to
have the right type of supervision and
Leadership and a culture where people
will be reported by their peers and then
a system that can push them out of the
organization at the moment police
regulations are unwieldy police Chiefs
aren't the ones who are making the
decisions about who should be sacked or
not
um and I think it's right that that is
being opened up for question yeah that
was interesting because the new met
police chief samark Rowley um in a
recent interview said that you know he
has to employ a hundred people who were
only allowed to work in Baton roles and
he said it's completely mad that I had
to employ people like that as police
officers who you can't trust have
contact with the public so is there a
problem about effective not be able to
thank people yes
um some years ago and I understand why
from a public perception point of view
um the makeup of police misconduct
panels was changed so that there's a
legally qualified chair rather than a
senior police officer who chairs those
panels I chaired dozens of those panels
during my my service and my experience
of sitting with lay members is that they
tend to be more sympathetic towards
police officers
um maybe more understanding uh you know
in a way that I felt actually they
shouldn't be and police officers have to
maintain the highest standards of
behavior because they're enforcing the
law on fellowship with fellow citizens
um so I do think that's one of a number
of things that should be looked at in
terms of the way police misconduct is
dealt with you know you obviously in the
worked for the police did you witness
any of this kind of behavior or was it
things that are I guess more generally
kept within groups of men or did you see
anything or right by the by the time I
joined the met I was very senior I was a
police officer for 30 years in in three
different police forces
um I'm not sure it's very helpful to
start talking about incidents that
happened 35 years ago but I think all
women who've worked in male-dominated
organizations
um um people from LGBT communities
people from different ethnic backgrounds
when you're in a minority within an
organization and that can feel like
quite a lonely place I think the recent
report about the fire service is is
worth a read and it includes in that an
example of what a good team looks like
where everyone feels that they're
pulling together and the different
strengths are seen to be making the team
more stronger
um themselves but I think sometimes when
you're the only one and the team ethos
is about
um a very traditional view
yeah which which emphasizes maybe the
physicality of policing or firefighting
and not recognizing that actually the
breadth of skills that you need to work
effectively as a team means that you
need different people within that team
yeah I thought one of the really
interesting parts of that report into
the London fire brigade was the figures
on just how white a male an organization
it is
um you've said before that policing is
an attractive career for sexual
predators bullies and bigots now I know
that you've also emphasized the really
good people who work in the police and
it's important to say that but what did
you mean by that well
as I as I said before as a police
officer you have power over your fellow
citizens and also the way
um policing tends to be portrayed in the
media it's about Pub fights it's about
driving cars fast it's the more Macho
side if you like of the role whereas
actually the figures show now about 80
percent of police incidents don't even
involve a crime uh the police more and
more are picking up issues that come
from people in Mental Health crisis
people with all sorts of vulnerabilities
missing children missing elderly people
and so on so
um
the way policing is seen if you start up
from from a position where maybe you are
a bully or a bigot it looks like an
attractive career to you and so that's
why recruitment training
um and an internal culture that does
report those who really don't deserve to
carry the warrant card or to wear the
uniform and there is increasing evidence
of that
um and Reporting hotlines and so on that
that people can use I went on one of
those websites the other day where
people give Anonymous reviews of their
employers and when you look at the one
for the Metropolitan Police there are a
number of people who say they're they're
former officers complaining that you
can't trust your colleagues any anymore
because they might report on you yeah
and I actually thought that that was a
very positive sign that people are
realizing you can't get away with
behavior where maybe you thought you
were safe in the past just to pick up
very quickly before we end on something
you just said 80 of police incidents
don't involve a crime yes I'm quite
staggered by that do you think that's
because you're effectively having to
take on a greater role in Pub where
Public Services other public services
like the Health Service or whatever are
stretched it's always been true but I
suspect even more so now
um policing sometimes gets called The
Social Services of Last Resort
of all the organizations that are
available 24 hours a day seven days a
week the police in effect are the last
ones left standing and I think we would
all want somebody to go and help the
most vulnerable in their hour of need
but the point that Mark Rowley is is
making at the moment is that that does
become a a distraction and depletes
resources from those incidents that
really only the police can deal with and
that's going to be a challenge for
Society for those
um deciding where where taxpayers money
goes within the public sector
fascinating didn't realize that at all
thank you so much for being on the
program today really interesting to talk
thank you Sophie well that is it for
this week's safety Ridge on Sunday
really busy program as today very
wide-ranging and in a moment after the
break we're going to be running through
today's interviews talking about what we
learned with some analysis from myself
and our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates thanks for joining us this Sunday
morning
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello good morning welcome to safer
Ridge the take where we look in a bit
more detail at what we've been talking
about with our guests in the last hour
so it was a really busy program lots of
different guests uh today including
nazim zahawi uh the chair of the
conservative party to help us go through
some of the interviews and have a bit of
analysis as well we're joined as usual
by adaptive political editor at Sam
Coates uh hello uh Sam so one of the
things that really sort of struck me
about the program today was to talk
about strikes I mean this was a pretty
brief Story by the government about
their contingency plans and what to do
about strike so it's clearly what they
kind of want to be talking about partly
I guess because of the huge disruption
that people are going to be facing this
winter but partly because I just wonder
if it is a more comfortable Battleground
for the conservative party at a time
when they're certainly short of those
what's your take Sam
I think that's right the headline that
ministers want this morning is that
essentially the military is going in to
in order to help all the various uh
relieve all the pressure caused by the
various different bits of strikes uh
that are taking place between now and
Christmas there's some kind of
industrial action every single day
between now and Christmas and uh the
headline that they want is the Army are
going in but it's really important
Sophie to just acknowledge exactly what
is and what isn't happening there are
600 Army Personnel who are currently
being trained to do certain tasks
starting as Nadine zahawi told you uh
with trying to help at our borders now
as the uh conservative party chairman
said to you that is the thing that the
government is legally bound to make sure
continues to function we can't have a
non-functioning border uh so so I think
quite a lot of these 600 will go
specifically to trying to solve that
problem in the event uh that those
Strikers are from the PCS Union don't
actually end up uh end up causing some
uh disruption so uh with quite a small
amount of training I understand it's
just five days uh Army Personnel will be
deployed to the front line but
um what this won't be is a wholesale
answer to the industrial action problem
yes they will help at Borders maybe they
will drive ambulances uh but beyond that
much of the disruption that viewers this
morning uh will experience in the last
two weeks well the Army won't be able to
help with that whether it's rail strikes
really whether it's nurses uh striking
of course uh neither the Armed Forces
nor the other civil servants being
drafted in as part of this special unit
uh will be able to particularly help and
therefore um yes they're trying to fight
on what might be traditionally
comfortable conservative territory this
morning
um but if they're promising what sounds
like an answer I suspect for many people
it won't feel like an answer in the
weeks and months to come it's
interesting as well because
um people always say that strikes aren't
just about pay but clearly pay is a big
part of it too and I was quite Keen to
talk to Nadeem zahari about whether
inflation matching pay Rises would be
reasonable he continued the government
line which is effectively that it won't
be and he talked an awful lot about
Vladimir uh Putin and not allowing
inflation caused by him to become
embedded I did put it to him that for
many people you know it's about survival
not just about beating inflation his
head's response
the chancellor came to the dispatch box
and delivered a 150 billion pound energy
package that this by the way if you take
that into equivalence that's equivalent
of the whole of the NHS to support
people's households otherwise their
energy bills would have uh spiked to
support businesses as well at the money
we're putting into helping those most
vulnerable uh the 8 million most
vulnerable households is significant we
have to come together this is not a time
to be divided to I hope send a very
clear message to Mr Putin that he can't
use energy as a weapon in this way and
we will remain United which is why we've
accepted accepted the pay review bodies
I guess NHS I guess and on schools you
know a nurse on 20 grand a year you you
would think that maybe there are other
ways of sending Putin a clear message on
Ukraine rather than the fact that you're
going to have to well no have a real
time but we wake up no but we've
accepted the the pay review body on
nurses and as I said to you last year
they got three percent the this year's
recommendation is 1400 pounds so the the
you know the starting salary of a nurse
would be a 31 000 pounds it is difficult
I am absolutely you know conscious of
the fact of how hard things are at the
moment but it's not a time to you know
go for 19 pay rise that will cost 10
billion pounds because if you you know
if you accept all the inflation uh level
pay Rises that's about 28 billion pounds
it costs every household just short of a
thousand pounds
um that is you know unsustainable when
we're trying to be fiscally disciplined
and bring inflation under control
because if inflation is embedded it'll
hurt those families those nurses even
more in the long term
at Nadeem sahawi talking now well let's
bring Sam back in is there a bit of a
dividing line would you say between the
government and labor on strikes
well it's fascinating Sophie because
there isn't really and what was
interesting about the thing we just
heard from Nadine zahawi was although
there were implied comparisons perhaps
between some of the union bosses and
Vladimir Putin also uh really he was
casting Vladimir Putin as the enemy for
pushing up uh inflation for pushing up
uh energy costs and the tone really in
the thing we've just seen is quite
emollient which is not a million miles
away from where labor are because labor
as we've been talking for anybody that's
seen us chat about politics in the last
few weeks put a labor politician
Frontline politician in front of you and
they will not answer the question of
whether or not there should be inflation
matching pay Rises and actually this
morning I thought that British Phillips
and went uh about as slash Easter Shadow
education secretary she went about as
far as you possibly could to actually
say say no labor wouldn't be doing
things particularly differently uh to
the government because she couldn't make
promises she couldn't afford to keep
let's hear a bit of her
well I do think it means recognizing the
pressure that people are into right now
but also over the last 12 years pay
hasn't been keeping up with demands that
workers in our Vital services are facing
but you can't get to a position of
agreement if you're not prepared to even
have that conversation and what I hear
time and again you know whether it's
real or our schools or the Health
Service ministers are just not prepared
to sit down and talk about these issues
properly I think trust in politics
matters and I'm not going to make
promises this morning to you that I
don't feel confident I can deliver I
think that's been what's so what's been
so corrosive to our politics in recent
years
foreign
because both the main political parties
are effectively saying that very very
similar things but there's a calculation
that underlines and it's actually
spelling them down this this graph is
effectively simply what's going to
happen with inflation now this line here
that's pretty much where we are at the
moment you can see inflation every
single politician whether you're labor
or Tori looks like it's about to Peak
but they're all really hoping that
within the space of just a year just
this very short timeline here that it's
going to plunge really really quickly so
the hope both for the Tories and for the
labor party is that inflation is a
problem now pay Rises pay disputes an
issue right now and for the next few
months but within just a year actually
inflation is brought back under control
but as the German ambassador told you
Sophie nobody knows whether or not the
situation in Ukraine the tensions with
Russia which is the thing that's been
pushing up prices uh prices uh having a
knock-on effect uh even dynasticity on
our policy nobody knows whether the
talks are going to sort sort things and
those tensions are going to go away
within that very very short time frame
that the office for Budget
responsibility says will deal with the
inflation crisis so whether you're Tory
or whether you're labor you're placing a
bet that the pain on pay is short term
the question is is all of this right
uh yeah it's quite interesting I thought
actually hearing the German ambassador
talk about some of those uncertainties
going on um Sam and Sam's going to show
you his um swing or motor I think uh
shortly but before he dies I just want
to talk a little bit about what Nadeem
zahawi said about some of the latest uh
you go of polling now remember of course
he used to run you got if you founded it
and now of course we're using his older
polling company to show at Labor sitting
particularly comfortably ahead of the
conservative party let's just listen to
uh what he had to say to the polls
if you actually look beneath the
headline a couple of things I would pull
out uh from that uh one when you ask
people the question if there is an
election tomorrow how would you vote
well people know there's no election
tomorrow so that response what you're
seeing there is currently there how they
feel about the the the government's
track record on delivery if you dig
beneath the data I'd be worried if I was
kissed armor because I would be worried
if you're okay
for one if you'll allow me right if you
if you look at his numbers it's very
soft there's not a great passion for
what K star must say certainly there's
no passion for him when he went before
the Trade union Congress saying he'll
repeal all of the Trade union
legislation that the conservatives have
brought in he's made that promise and if
you ask that same people is that a good
thing or a bad thing I think most of
them will say it's a bad thing
it's pretty admirable optism is optimism
there by the conservative party chairs I
think it's curious darma who should be
worried if he looks at that graphic he
was also I thought interesting at how he
was talking about the conservatives
would be absolutely fine that next
election if they just get to grips with
the small boats uh an illegal migration
tackle inflation and a whole load of
other things that are going to be pretty
thorny issues at the least to uh sort
out let's bring Sam back in uh shall we
we just looked at the kind of raw
polling data there but you've been
working on tool haven't you along with
uh yougarve that shows what it would
mean if there was an election so what
have you been looking at
that's right Sophie and I have to say if
I was looking to buy shares in yougov I
wouldn't particularly buy them in the
event that I was listening to Nadine
zahar we talk about the the role and use
of polling because it wasn't
particularly complimentary about the
company that he founded but let's have a
look at where we actually are and we're
going to use this tool called a swing
omitter which looks at what happens if
at the next election the public go
towards the uh decide that they want to
vote for labor in greater numbers or the
conservatives now if there is no change
in public support at the next election
uh then the swingometer would point back
down there but the labor party needed an
eight percent swing in order just to get
an unstable Coalition and clearstana to
enter number 10 a 12 swing in order to
get an overall majority and to get a
landslide uh they need about 20 swing
that's all the way up here but the point
I want to hammer home safely is that
labor did so badly as a last election
that they've got an enormous mountain to
climb to do all of those things so so
just for comparison in 1997 when Blair
got a landslide he'd only took him a
swing of 10 kissed armor needs 12 just
to have a majority of one so actually
life is much harder than it's been for
any labor leader in recent years now
let's go back to that Chester
by-election that we were talking about
uh on uh Thursday night Friday morning
and here's the swing for him here 13 uh
point six percent uh that's the uh the
swing that the labor party managed to
achieve uh on Thursday night now Ian
Duncan Smith Nadine zahawi perhaps
suggesting that that swing could have
been bigger but it's still bigger than
the swing that labor achieved in 1997 uh
in order to give Blair that Landslide
yes it might only result in a 30 or so
uh majority in the event that uh in the
event that that was replicated uh in an
election but you've got to take into
account that actually labor needs to get
so many seats and a big majority in
order to recline that mountain that
means actually all of this is pretty
hard for them so it's not a bad result
given the scale of the task that they
face that's really interesting to see it
all mapped out there and actually
particularly that comparison between
Tony Blair and kirst armor to show at
just what a more challenging job at the
current labor leader does have but
certainly if the things are replicated
at the minute in a general election
looks like labor on track for majority
Sam thanks very much for your analysis
we've backed you in just one minute
because the other clip from the program
that I was quite Keen to show you was
from the German ambassador to the UK
Miguel uh Berger Sam mentioned him a
little bit earlier on but he was quite
open I thought on the program whether
you know it's talking about China or
Ukraine but in particular on brexit I
was asking him if there could be a
breakthrough in the deadlock over
post-brexit trade agreements because it
does feel as though there is I guess a
bit more optimal them perhaps from the
EU side with Rishi sunac in post let's
have a listen
we don't see a fundamental change in the
Russian position
Putin continues this really terrorizing
the civilian population we are very
concerned about that because these
attacks on the energy infrastructure
mean that many people with freezing
temperatures might be forced to leave
Ukraine so we expect another wave of
refugees in the coming weeks so but to
your question no we don't see for the
foreseeable future a willingness to
engage in the Diplomatic solution I
think that we have now a different basis
for negotiations I see an openness to
engage they have already been talks and
yes I would say I'm cautiously
optimistic because in the end there is a
landing zone for the Northern Ireland
protocols implementation it is possible
to find a solution the difficult issue
is is more the political on the reaction
of the dup the risk of a of an election
in Northern Ireland so there are many
political issues which go together with
it we see also very positively that
labor is willing to have a very close
relationship with Europe and I think the
rest we will have to leave it now to the
negotiations because if we achieve a
solution on Northern Ireland then this
will help also to develop other areas of
cooperation so I would see the solution
of the Northern Ireland protocol
question as a first step
well let's bring in our Deputy political
editor at Sam coats we heard a bit about
Russia there but I just want to focus on
uh brexit if I may and because it does
feel like from the EU side they think
perhaps Rishi sunak is someone they can
do business with do you think that's
fair to say
I think Rishi Cena likes to still see
himself as a deal maker I think that's
actually like what lies behind the tone
on the unions and from everything that
we can tell and to be honest which
assume that hasn't said a lot publicly I
think that's his approach when it comes
to brexit and the Northern Ireland
protocol he thinks that he can make
breakthroughs he thinks the alternative
we know from leaks of discussions that
he had even when Boris Johnson was prime
minister he thinks the alternative of
going back to war with Europe having a
trade war that could mean tariff slaps
on Goods at this point where the economy
is so perilous he seems to think that
that's a bad course of action and
therefore we believe he wants to strike
a deal uh and uh this appears to be what
the Europeans are telling us they're
finding in private discussions as well
but any kind of deal on Northern Ireland
any kind of deal on brexit is a big big
risk for Richie sunap because it's going
to involve compromises compromises of
the sort that people like Ian Duncan
Smith who you had in your Studios aren't
going to like it's probably going to
involve compromises uh over the role of
European courts and Northern Ireland
it's possibly going to involve
compromises uh about uh exactly what
checks uh take place and are overseen uh
by the EU so very very thorny territory
for rissy sunac and so I suspect that
the more positive noises you get out of
Europe the more worries there are uh
domestically from Tory MPS and I also
asked the German ambassador about the
controversial VR decision in the Japan
game do you think they've all went over
the limestone
um uh I'm with him
thanks very much and
to ask about the World Cup so obviously
I can't I can't resist squeezing
something in at the end of the program
uh thanks very much always a good sport
uh Sam uh thank you for the uh World Cup
analysis in particular
well that is it it's from Sophie Ridge
on Sunday the take uh for this morning
uh the podcast will be following around
lunchtime that's got the best bits from
our interviews plus some analysis uh
from me and the team as well so do watch
out for this one it has been busy a few
months certainly on Sophie Ridge on
Sunday do check out our Wednesday show
as well uh the take care with safety
Ridge that's 9pm at Wednesdays uh always
a bit of a roller coaster uh week uh for
us particularly of course with so much
to come whether it's strike action and
of course the issue of small boats which
certainly feels like it's won but is it
going away for the government thanks
very much for watching have a great
Sunday
foreign
[Music]
[Music]